votar malta
então o almoço foi bom
a questão é esse índice
eu vou fazer primeiro uma pergunta e mas
antes da pergunta vou cavar uma
apresentar isso agora e acontecerão no
terceiro ano da licenciatura de economia
mista e por causa da china em 96 e
fazendo as contas tem 20 anos e me
perguntar e keke é de 96 já que esta
queda de 96
o beijing e 96 para baixo as mais velhas
e pra cima mas nós aqui mata mas não é
questão é que eu vou estar geral não é
bom não terminar tipo de idade e começou
uma pergunta quem é que é músico
profissional e amador mas por exemplo eu
pergunto quem é que sabe tocar guitarra
por exemplo ganha muita gente treina e
piano piano mas agora eu pergunto quem
sabe
fonte é porque não foi
fui a questão de foi feito foi o o
senhor da minha terra surge em que o
bioma mais e em sintra depois de
substituir as gatas do vidigal terra é e
eu disse a eles tudo bem mas por questão
é porque eu fui até fofa quinto com 20
anos para um metro e meio como eu que
quer ganhar de forma macro tomando aí é
e eu não tenho uma pancada e quesito
claro pra mim
ano terá um review com isto mas pode não
ser nada mas no futuro tempo te dizer
uma coisa pra olha sem tocar gaita e voz
e no futuro podem pedir andré o
espetáculo zinho e há uma grande falta
apenas definir seu terceiro caro ou não
se são estas pequenas coisas que podem
não trazer nada mas podem ter êxito
depois no futuro eu comecei com isso
porque eu vou usar uma frase com o
professor é que o que eu tive em dia
muitas vezes e fazer assim não deixe que
o estudo entre filha na modificação não
deixem os 30 filho vocação é um então
vou fazer que eu no outro lado notou
sido calor aumenta suspenso
a medicação está no cinturão e estar a
atirar economia ou gestão técnico em
questão é o primeiro no primeiro lance
achei estranho e não é é dizer é que o é
e depois te faz sentir o que estava a
dizer por exemplo é eu vivi uma nova
colina e nós somos 50
lá dentro é e muita malta só tem as
manhãs e temas à tarde e isso faz com
que também devemos imaginar têm aulas de
manhã e à tarde aproveita o tempo para
que 90 e mesmo essa gente passa de dois
anos até a hora de sentar em uma piscina
eu não consigo não nunca se está a ficar
calado esse tempo todo o resto técnicas
mas essa luz 18 essa luz é um de 1918 de
18 a 19 mas somou no uma quinta e que
passam a vida toda a história toda a
cidade eo risco de o ouvir um colega meu
que se candidatou estágio é branco
epá surda que os testes do xpto para
acontecer às técnicas e com e contextos
matemática e decore minha mas o estudo
chegou ontem em entrevista em entrevista
pessoal e pergunta o que te dizer nada
não tem nada para dizer depois que um
barco no istres uma pessoa passa o tempo
todo a estudar e não traz apenas também
estuda quem muito importante e passa o
tempo todo errado
os livros e não faz o outro mas não
adiantou que não tem que ser não tens
irmã não tem um ser obrigatória opa
coisas pequenas que podem fazer todo o
sentido pois já estamos desenvolvendo
com pessoas é e eu xingo como a vacina
nos trechos de entrevistas pessoais na
última fase o que não quer dizer eu
tenho hoje tem feito fase fique sentado
na cadeira 'ajuda' obrigado é que não é
é muito importante o estudo
mas o facto é que essas coisas podemos
fazer e pode não se dirige o tempo é uma
competência bastando que nós temos e não
estou a dar conselhos news mas acho que
é bastante importantes é esta situação
começaram seu músico
neste terceiro ano de de caminhões toda
a minha cintura e decide intervir em
tudo que é o primeiro ano da
universidade e foi descoberto o que
podemos fazer não sei que eu pensei
assim não é uma coisa
o primeiro era dos meus alunos e menos
no futuro e agora toca flauta
transversal e veria e tem um sms grupos
ponto k é em leiria e lisboa também ti é
uma questão de tempo não pára
também preocupado mas ao mesmo tempo
ajudam no range aí é uma coisa que gosto
de fazer e que dá prazer fazer e que no
futuro a temporada bastante jeito para o
que quer que seja
no terceiro ano da setur eo pimento dia
e descobrir 11 que no universo muita
muito só não conhece o empreendorismo
sediar no terceiro ano
seu estagiário porque tinha que fazer
alguma coisa e isso também
vice-presidentes martin uma organização
que a e entrarmos no mundo do
empreendedorismo o empreendedorismo é o
típico exemplo do desenrasca tuga não há
nada definido
as coisas bombardeando com coisas
urgentes com atividades em situações nos
fazem também não só como técnico mas
também como os sites muitos sites no
final do ano
não damos muitas hoje sim para não dorme
acho que é enriquecedor ficou dizendo
nunca leu que estuda no isep estão em 20
anos
eu tenho quatro empresas já eu tenho
passaporte normal porque não conseguia
todo tarde as aulas e controlar quatro
empresas
o caso mais interessante é como eu crio
a última empresa deu que chama o balão
que o balão é fazer o teste do balão vez
em quando não as portas desses técnicos
é no algarve tempo
em dois dias eu ter vestido a itu final
só se vê lo e para o chico tem uma
grande idéia e vamos fazer a empresa do
bolão
vamos fazer esse baixo teclas vai votar
no algarve vilamoura e vamos procurar
fazer contatos e comprou pois a máquina
e os domingos para motos por ano e
depois eu disse é também eu preciso que
ele repetisse
é eu acho que tem teclas e começou a
dizer que a empresa
esta semana vamos estar no algarve eu
tenho aquela criar empresa eu nunca
estiveram há nenhum eu vou estar no
algarve
então eu fui pois bogar e durante o
grande dia
sua placa catarse entoado em postes de
leccionado em um ano naquela que acham
que estão apenas a praia e tudo
no final deste dia acabou por empate
técnico falou com o gerente da discoteca
e teve mês passou o resto do verão em
vilamoura fazer os testes do do balão do
que o que eu disse essa história porque
seu exemplo típico de da malta que
diferenciava e eu posso não ter grande
onda repressiva que não tem né porque
tem imensa coisa que eu diria é e esse é
questão de gosto e decidiu criar uma
coisa muito importante não arranjar
desculpas
daí que fazemos e que conhecemos e que
fazemos acontecer pois é é e deixa o pai
e minha mãe e minha família e eu
compreendo em partida que tenho a dizer
é uma coisa que os meus pais me deram
quando vemos podem ser principalmente
também não é boa foi liberdade irá dizer
que são os vossos pais que na maioria
estão a pagar para você está aqui tem
liberdade que vos deram agora mas tem um
outro mundo para conseguir fazer o que
vocês quiserem desde que seja vulture
alunos desde que seja fazer é que é pior
mas não fique assim tarde partidária é
eu digo eu gostava de ver o time em tudo
e com seus lugares mais frios da cabeça
e essa malta é modo de dizer acho que
está a fazer e faz acontecer diz vai
acontecer mas faz acontecer
são estas coisas
o que faz crer num por não ser nada e
tudo pois no no futuro
é isso é é uma questão que nós entramos
na universidade a universidade só para
tirar o curso na minha opinião está
desaproveitado imenso universidade
nós podemos apenas ok temos as aulas mas
acho que temos é de aproveitar
completamente conhecida por exemplo do
sul revela o ief fazemos pode não ser
nada vou fazer vela foi porque sem fazer
dela porque ele aprenderá a fazer bela
mas tem imensos a outras ordens de um
espólio marcar a diferença
a opção que o psoe cleitão da
universidade de lisboa
eu disse uma frase uma vez foi uma
conferência com é um eles uma coisa
bastante interessante que nós vamos
punir cidade para estarmos aquilo que
queremos e estamos a minha mãe fosse um
carinho quando o ouviu dizer isso por
anos e agora temos de ver esse estudo
que querem e não há correspondência como
cá trabalho objetivo é ter um trabalho e
receber dinheiro e nós estamos aqui o
que fazemos isso nos empenhamos trabalho
por nós nem que seja em outra área mas
há cerca de dois anos em maio o país que
música é essa cena do curso sério é
porque não há cursos que têm mais no
brincar e fazer as coisas e é
conseguirmos dizer que ia fazer outras
atividades fazê los
subestimá lo e opep não tem que ser
se ele aprender línguas e por exemplo
fui aprender russo também porque foi
também uma semana culpar a rússia por me
fazerem anos foi completa mil é paula
não vamos fazer ajustes nos bairros e
vamos da equipe longe vamos aprender e
aprendemos é também fui aprender
espanhol ano de aos mesmos também se
fala inglês né
não estamos aqui por é a imensa coisa
que podemos fazer
paula ainda do que todo o caso que o
estudo da universidade é esse tão
difícil para o cairo
a mensagem que o que vocês estivessem é
que daqui 80 anos
olhem pra voce passado e não me
arrependo nada tenham feito porque uma
das coisas que está muito fácil
enfrentar pena não ter feito aquilo que
é feito com o outro e e não tem feito
não sei que a opção não ser pelo não não
tenho arrependimentos na vida façam têm
todas as capacidades que aquela pessoa é
cada pessoa mas que não é como cada qual
mas cada um cachorro que precisa para
acrescentar algo à qualquer coisa que
queira diferencia se mexeu cool vão para
onde você quiser não saindo em turnê é
façam atividades que vocês caíram faça
um curta estão estão do tempo e do
estudo e não aconteça muito boa
vocês estão nos cuidar e fazer um
futebol fazia um ginásio ou faziam bom e
fizemos faz música faz música ainda é
visto por por último porque não tem
tempo pra não é uma coisa é a gestão do
tempo temos de ir banho o que nós temos
o dia tem 24 horas em 24 a 17
tudo o tempo todo o tempo
não há uma topada mas arranja spam
quer dizer é que sejam sejam fui pago a
uma frase muito importante que é
importante é ter saúde ea questão a
questão é não se arrependam pois no
futuro não ter feito onde vai tem
histórias para contar aos meus filhos e
os continentes
se quiserem ter claro tem história pra
contar no futuro não se arrependam
depois não haver não terem feito no
faces realizadas pessoalmente e ter
apenas feito curso e pó por cá trabalho
que o cuca dessas vezes eu queria bancar
óleo mas quer fazer uma coisa que é
minha e quero deixar não quer ser um
número quer ser o andré leonel moreira
entrou no não sei onde está a marcar a
diferença porque a moto tinha se
conhecido também é muito importante
ainda ontem eu fui pedir é eu estava no
universidade
não sei se vocês conhecem o céu dias
minhas
o judoca portuguesa olímpico foi jogos
olímpicos e está a ajudar-nos p perdeu e
ficou mais nervoso que eu realmente acho
que não vão pedir autógrafos por não
conhecem só com essa é uma montanha mas
eu faço parte da equipa velho telma
monteiro e fotografia ficou a dormir
resultado um autógrafo mil m tem um
abraço andré assina ou não disse nada
ganho o dia por alguém ter conhecido a
ficou contente se provem ter conhecido
ea questão é é mais importante nós já
conhecemos seus conhecidos fora cá
dentro e é em nós e nós conseguimos
fazer as atividades e empreendedores
como professores ativos nos encher a
mensagem missions é não não sei
desculpas sejam felizes e mexa ocupa
[Aplausos]